I talked to so many actors that had kind
of a great fantasy life when they were
kids I think it's part of being able to
be a shape-shifter and an actor as you
get older and you were like that right
yeah you had like imaginary friends you
had like a kind of pretend world you'd
go to yeah but like I wasn't original
with it you know what I mean so like my
imaginary friend was he lived in my
mom's mirror one of those big mirrors in
your bedroom and it was Elvis Presley
yeah your imaginary friend was a real
was a real Presley I lack the
imagination but I got a little bit yeah
you know and so yeah that's so weird to
cuz he's not even like of your
generation
he was super dead by this you're dead
for a while and then there's a point
where you hit super day were you friends
with young Elvis or old fat leather
Elvis honestly the older I got the more
and more I really wish that I could have
met the sweaty fat Elvis preferably but
when I was younger it was like the super
young you know blue eyes dark lashes
leather jacket we were there I used to
think that he was my boyfriend
and he used to tell people that he was
my boyfriend and mine too I'm four years
old and he's super dead and and like my
mom would like have her girls over and
they'd be drinking wine and they'd be
like Alex what who's your boyfriend was
like mom you know it's Elvis like quit
playing with me like you understand that
he's my man like they didn't they didn't
have the heart to tell me he was super
dead
yeah well that's sweet and also very sad
you